[Music]
welcome back to just kidding news
the show is off the record where we talk
about whatever we want
okay
what is that oh your little jack quagga
wire
how did you even find that dude i was in
mexico i know but i've i've been in
mexico and i never [ __ ] find that i
got it from a mexican so you're not real
mexican oh you ever seen a real mexican
there yeah i've ever seen a real one
guess not he said real mexican
come over here for the jaguar and i said
okay thank you and i bought it for three
dollars oh [ __ ] that's time
damn that thing was only three bucks
it's probably hand painted and
everything yeah it's made by the hands
of a mayan child but that feels like
that would only be a souvenir thing i
can't see a local yeah none of my
aunties and uncles have that [ __ ] greet
you at the door with a jaguar call that
looks like a souvenir to you
i don't think you understand mexican
culture this is so authentic it's mayan
okay it's not even mexican anymore it's
just mayan you mean aztec no mayan oh it
is it's mayan yeah oh
these i i got blessed by a mayan um
shaman too
he put water on some
i don't know something and he slapped me
with it oh was that like was that eight
bucks that was about ten bucks yeah they
had a temple or something or no it was
it was a it was at a tour stop
it was during the tour yeah it was like
on the bus no yeah and it was an
obsidian store he's just like throwing
you back water on a map and he was like
this is a mexican tradition and we had
mayan push pops
authentic authentic cold mayan pushback
it was an obsidian store just had a
bunch of obsidian oh i love obsidian
dude proceeds would go to teaching
indigenous kids how to
speak language how to cut
obsidian
yeah and then um
they were like would you like to have
your obsidian blessed and i was like oh
yeah let's do it and he started chanting
saying stuff in mayan and then he
slapped me in the face with it put water
all over my body and he's like all right
you're done i hate a man to slap you in
the face
he slapped me with the
the leaves what kind of obsidian did you
get like it was a frog oh yeah [ __ ]
that's tight i forgot what it meant like
it meant like stuff i don't know it
meant something but i got it because i
was like it's for the kids
it was such a tourist trap i swear to
god it was just a store with a bunch of
uh like obsidian and stuff no i hate
that [ __ ] you hate it
[ __ ] like that like tourist places that
yeah i don't like it like teaching
children how to fish for their own like
yeah i don't feel like that's true i
hate children i'm always so skeptical
especially if it's like in a tourist
spot i'm just like nah this is sketch i
don't trust it or like animal [ __ ] like
when they have the tigers and like oh
you're talking about like
tiger cubs anything that's touristy i
hate it do you feel like someone's
getting exploited somewhere sure yeah on
our cruise we uh stopped in what was in
sonata or something and then there's
that one place where you're going to get
seafood but for some reason there's like
a wild cat exhibit and then so they're
like before you get your lobster you
want to take a picture oh yeah we did
walk through that it was like there's
like rainforest cafe with actual animals
yeah yeah yeah and they bring they bring
out like this half tranquilized tiger
yeah you're like oh that's kind of sad
looking did you get a photo though no
good for you we didn't eat there we just
walked through like nope
nope not in there no i would have got a
picture going
with the little cup
right
yeah i can't do [ __ ] like that or like
swimming with dolphins and doing all
that [ __ ] where they explain why you
can't swim with dolphins why not
dolphins because they're just like
what if they're wild and they come to
you well if it's wild then it's fine no
that's sad can it really happen in the
wild naturally though in an unscary way
would they come up and play with you
yeah dude i go snorkeling and i'm if i
see a school of like like harmless
looking fish coming my way i am freaking
the [ __ ] we went snorkeling in hawaii uh
with the one where it's on a boat do
they take you where it's way more remote
and there's a place where i was swimming
and i saw a six foot manta ray yo wait
yeah in mexico mexico we went we went
snorkeling there was like a huge crazy
amount of like stingrays though and it
was like super scary you took a picture
with it uh it was on my gopro and it was
probably like if i was here yeah the
manta is probably where that shelf is
over that's how close it was yeah as
people who are part of the influencing
network do animals because your baby is
a boost right an engagement animal yeah
are animals engagement boosters big time
dogs
we had dogs i follow so many yeah people
have their own instagram for their like
dog or their kids there's so many dogs
and children so if you took a picture
with said tiger would that have been a
performer especially with a sentiment
now maybe like eight years ago when
people didn't know about like i think
after tiger king and all these
documentaries people know oh dude after
cte i don't even feel comfortable taking
a picture with a boxer anymore
like doing this [ __ ]
did the boxers look in the wrong
direction wait let's see
i was walking by this um petting like
one of those petting things right with
all the cubs and i was like super
judging it i was like man [ __ ] that [ __ ]
and i looked and then there was a baby
jaguar and a white tiger just rolling
around playing and i was like oh i wanna
i wanna go pet them so bad and i was
like [ __ ] i'm not gonna support them
thank you joe then i was like but wait
no they need money too because they're
poor but these people need to feed their
kids that's so sad they don't get pets
kitties love pets but i kept walking
back and forth and i was like i don't
know what to do
well tell me what you did and then there
was a mayan dance going on so i went
over there and i got distracted and i
was recording them okay good bye i
didn't end up petting the cubs whenever
you always need sliced rib eye steak
just in your pocket ready to go so you
can give some little cats some food oh
that's
like i don't know why they follow me so
much
i do have a plan bart does have a smell
to them slice through it by sliced
ribbons pockets we did go to a wolf
sanctuary and that was really cool is it
better because it's a sanctuary yeah
because they're there to get rescued
yeah because they take it from people
that are like oh it'd be fun to have a
[ __ ] wolf as a [ __ ] pet so you
agree with tiger king then that
sanctuary is cool not tiger king well
what did he do did he wrestle sanctuary
no he wasn't this the one he had a zoo
but then
uh carol baskins had like a cat
sanctuary
sanctuaries i'm okay any fathom expired
meats can you look in the camera and say
you're okay with carol baskin
carol baskins is a-okay with me she took
over the tiger king's place and then she
lost it oh what the [ __ ] because the
pandemic [ __ ] it up like no one was
coming which is nuts because that's when
they she blew up right everybody do you
think people want to watch that show if
it wasn't for the pandemic true i hope
that's i feel like they would have
that's a wild story i just couldn't i
couldn't believe what i was watching as
it continued i was like this gets
there's no way this can get crazier than
this is that what this got crazy maybe
not that viral though it was massively
viral yeah it was nuts because like he
got married to both of those dudes at
the same time right it was like a
three-way wedding and one of them was
super hot i know and that's one that
killed himself
that one was straight too so i met him
but he's the real king though isn't he's
the real king
taming all the beasts
human and tigers both kingdoms yeah
well except for of course
the disney kingdom all right that would
be the triple feat nobody's done it the
triple p nobody's done kind of hard to
yeah yeah you got a [ __ ] disney
princess right but in his case that
would have never happened what disney
princess would you want to [ __ ] all of
them well okay there's an order which
one's first okay ariel's mouth for sure
[Laughter]
that's true you can't really [ __ ] her
i don't even know who all the princesses
are just the ones you know snow white
cinderella belle is shipping yeah she's
a princess jasmine jasmine
cinderella i have to say is always
pretty hot whenever whenever i'm at
disney the live one i'm always like damn
that's pretty plain to me she is i want
the candle on beauty and the beast i
want the beast
i didn't [ __ ] all of them stuff for snow
white
oh she looks kind of old school i don't
like just short hairs weird
she had a baby i could get it though i
thought you were thinking about what she
did with with those with the dwarfs
there's actually a snow white porno that
came out in the 70s i'm not surprised
yep and then there's a scene where they
do a gang bang with all the dwarfs oh is
that what they did with it
yeah i wasn't sure either i was thinking
the prince probably oh definitely didn't
get there and then at the end uh the
prince wakes her up and then the dwarfs
are all watching and they're like yay oh
they watched him all the time they also
did her too well she was asleep no they
were she wasn't asleep they didn't take
advantage of her being asleep nope wow
what twist he came and [ __ ] her awake
do you think bill cosby watched it and
he was really disappointed
he's like
what the [ __ ] guys he's out now you can
probably go out and go ask him are you
kidding me i waited i waited for this to
download it
for so long what about you is there a
prince that you'd want to [ __ ] oh i mean
obviously i think eric is the hottest
eric
yeah little maureen yeah yes
black blue eyes he's a fish [ __ ]
though i can't get past that he is a
fish [ __ ] and uh what do you call
those fish [ __ ] usually animalities
pescatarian i think this is terrible
didn't [ __ ] her until he was she was
like had the legs though right so it's
like different she's not a fish anymore
true dude zeus her dad was [ __ ] fine
too her dad was hella fine
silver fox huh beside right yeah king
trident dog triton triton yeah oh i like
lilo's sister
she was hot
the older sister today's video is
brought to you by upstart
now i hope most of you guys aren't like
me
and um you're living with credit card
debt month to month to month to month to
month to month to month you're doing
that right now
some unfortunately but here's the cool
stuff okay upstart can help you with
that and help you get out of that debt
that situation needs to get rid of and
maybe i should be taking my own advice
yeah what's cool about upstart is it's a
very easy way to get a loan or to pay
off existing loans or to consolidate
credit card data especially if you have
five different credit cards you
consolidate all of that and there's over
half a million people that have used
upstart already upstart also knows
you're more than just a credit score so
they expand and look at everything about
who you are to make that decision if
you're worthy of a loan or not yeah
they'll check your income
who you work for your employment history
there's a bunch of other information on
top of just your credit score and the
cool thing is you can do this all online
and it only takes five minutes to sign
up and to check if you qualify or not
and if you do qualify you could get this
as fast as the next business day
and the range is in between anywhere
from a thousand to fifty thousand
dollars this is a lot of madness very
very many minus so find out how upstart
can lower your monthly payments today by
going to upstart.com off the record
that's upstart.com
off the record and make sure you use our
url so they know that we
sent you and the loan amount will be
determined by your credit your income
and other certain information that you
put on your loan application make sure
you go to upstart.com
off the record
do you know on youtube a part of the
reason why the adpocalypse thing
happened is because so many people were
trying to trick kids into i saw those
because it would get on it would get on
kids youtube and it would be like some
weird [ __ ] like 3d animated thing
that was like yeah
that was weird that was one [ __ ] during
the pandemic that really [ __ ] me up is
uh when you started really realizing all
the [ __ ] child porn cases
and then like all the like all the elite
conspiracies and that should just [ __ ]
through the weight conspiracy
well the epstein conspiracy a complete
conspiracy by the way
you know so that [ __ ] all [ __ ] me up
that one that was going around was the
hollywood one remember that yeah
was it like the corey feldman thing in
the no it was something else but it was
it was it was like tom like tom hanks is
a part of it uh what's that like a
satanist cult christian
yes he's so weird do you ever go on his
instagram he's [ __ ]
there's signs happening he's still
stupid he's weird yes he's [ __ ] weird
he's on a weird show too he's been
famous for a long ass time so sometimes
too i look at famous people like they're
not weird like because we're gauging
them off of a normal person yeah he's
been famous for like 50 years they're in
a different world yeah so you think that
fame bubble just kind of like eventually
makes you
weird but not weird to yourself because
weird to the normal person that's why
i'm just going to try not to be that
famous i mean i i'm considered weird
same thing imagine i could be more
popping but i'm like i'm gonna just
preserve my normality yeah it's gonna be
relatable because it's like a
bodybuilder that was like maybe 200
pounds right and he starts getting
buffer and buffer and then by the time
he's like 300 to a normal person you're
like what the [ __ ] why would you even
need to be that big but for him and
compared to his friends he's like i'm
only like 10 pounds heavier than my 290
buddy true
they're just in their own world and
that's how they're thinking about it
people think we're weird and then like
no you're weird i'm fine i'm [ __ ]
weird okay
[Laughter]
there's a reason why this [ __ ]
sells i'm not the only person you're
weird as quirky weird but
we all know bobby who people always
compare me to and we know that he's been
in the game for a very long time
and that is normal hollywood he's not
been in the howie mandel game no no
that's even longer so that's that's like
imagine so that level of success yeah
yeah so it's like different levels yeah
imagine if i was mega famous and then i
was 30 years older i don't think you
guys are weird at all i don't know
because you're also weird no i think i'm
very normal i did like that's like
should be on my like advertisement card
i'm a very young person personally
yeah are we going in the same direction
i love my partner so much that would eat
their poop that's very normal that's not
normal i heard howie mandel say some
[ __ ] like that too yeah yeah no he
didn't
quote it he eats poop i heard what is
normal because
already la is not normal to the rest of
america i think normal means i could put
you in any scenario and you're going to
behave in a way that's logical to the
circumstances oh
he's not normal no he's not normal i'm
pretty normal i think you're normal i
wouldn't bring you somewhere where i
have to like disclaim and be like he's
gonna get that's bobby see i won't take
a poop in the middle of the [ __ ]
floor in front of everybody you almost
did though yeah but by purpose not
because it's like it's an idea of this
would be funny and shocking not like
close because i think that's gonna [ __ ]
my pants and i was gonna i just i was
gonna do it on jill's front door
yeah you see
you're not part of this group dude fine
the more that you know him the more you
kind of pick that up
and it's he's still a candidate on your
list okay i think so i mean what did you
say that you did that was very
intriguing to me i don't know i know yes
you're into bus stuff
i like that you're a rece you like
nipple play too right oh yeah it's
awesome yeah i think he's just
getting my nipple sucked while i'm
getting jacked off
peace
[Laughter]
peace yeah farewell
to the loot peace my mind is gone
[Laughter]
that's amazing i just feel like normal
is repressed crazy yes appropriately
repressed and then for me i'm just too
repressed you're not normal oh right
like kind of mormony and like
too rigid and everything's like oh
everything's a little bit too neat and
clean around here yeah repressed to the
point where it's like you need to let
something out and that's something crazy
and then not caring and being impulsive
i guess that's not normal because people
are considerate of how other people
might view them yes that's too crazy on
the other end well in the right time
right place type of [ __ ] exactly like
when you're when you're going to to the
bathroom or whatever you're you're going
in the urinal you're not trying to like
go in all the urinals at the same time
which you do in elementary school right
yeah because you're worried that
everyone in elsinore would be like what
the [ __ ] are you doing yeah which is a
good thing
you'd also be peeing all over the ground
and creating a lot of extra work for
somebody not if you're like really good
at like just pinching it off and just
like yeah just going 1-1
seeing bart do that to our dog once what
wait sorry
yeah i remember tyson so he got to the
point where he was just so old it wasn't
like a sexual he's like 13 14. yeah and
then like he just couldn't control his
bladder and then
sometimes he would just be inside the
house and then it would just go and he's
a [ __ ] hundred pound dog so it's a
lot like pouring a gallon of water on
the ground yeah so then bart's like oh
[ __ ] and we don't know what to do and
we're i'm trying to run and go get a
towel and this [ __ ] dog's still
pissing so bart's like well let's see
what this does and he just pinched his
dick
i pinched his dick and i carried him out
i thought that you said that he peed on
the dog oh
i [ __ ] something oh my gosh i was
sitting here and i was like i don't have
any popcorn
my bad my mistake i [ __ ] up i pitched
his penis i took you down the wrong side
good setup sorry damn i wish i would
have known i would have kept it i was
like this is going to be but that's how
believable it is for bart to pee on the
w yeah
no no one questioned it people were like
that's a problem tyson feel more
comfortable bart started peeing on the
ground i would believe that too
we even have a jk party where we had to
take out these frozen shirts and he peed
on the frozen shirt to thaw it out
quicker oh you're forgetting a very
important key part of that what then he
put it on
or did i you did we do have showers
built into jk we're very normal why did
you have to do that to win a challenge i
like to win
i like to win i like to be competitive
the game was thaw out the t-shirt as
fast as possible and put it on yeah and
his solution was to pee on it i also
like to mess around did you win that's
actually pretty that's right
if he lost it would be incredible and
he's wearing a t-shirt were you turned
on at that moment were you like i picked
that person uh seven billion i chose
that one when he doesn't do like [ __ ]
made [ __ ] like when he like boom p
doesn't like affect him i'm like oh [ __ ]
that's [ __ ] hot some man [ __ ] so when
he goes in the backyard it picks up dog
[ __ ] with his bare hands your [ __ ] gets
wet in your life
that's a man yeah cause i'm like like
[ __ ] doesn't disturb you like [ __ ] yeah
like if some [ __ ] some real [ __ ] hits
the fan like i know this is just baby
[ __ ] for him he takes a hard right on
the freeway without even looking
and the person behind him has to super
[ __ ] break and like go like this she
was like that's a man
that's not just
my man
that's my man that's a mag
and the person calls her wife like i
love you so much i don't know what just
happened
i just needed to tell you i came close
to me
yeah i just don't like squirmy [ __ ] like
if you're a man and you're [ __ ] like
i'm like oh you ain't mad get the [ __ ]
out of here
we're turning on one does bart ever be
is he ever squirmy of over nothing at
all really nothing there's one time i
think tyka had a bloody nose and he
didn't have [ __ ] tissue or anything
bart's just like [ __ ] it he just lit i'm
like ah
now he had a bloody nose and then i
didn't have i was like plugging it for
him
and then i was i didn't have any like
paper towels two fingers i had it right
there and then uh
and then i
pulled it out there's blood all over the
place and i was like
oh [ __ ]
this is why bart doesn't need to flirt
barton doesn't need a flare he just
needs to exist i think that's what it is
we uncovered it everybody the geo just
gets wet i thought bart has the same
stupid ass solution to everything
tyson's peeing he's [ __ ] pinching the
pee he's
his son's bleeding he pinches the nose
you gotta plug the holes man
and every time he was like i'm [ __ ]
coming here
oh goddammit hey i'm gonna [ __ ]
hey
[Music]
you